[Musique]
à paris quelques piques à toulouse ou
encore à nice des milliers de personnes
vont encore se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire comme je
lai indiqué l'autre jour si nous serons
pas contraints de procéder 1re
confinement total ou partiel la
situation sanitaire et vous le savez
préoccupante étendu en direct de
boulogne sur mer nous avons la visite
d'olivier vers ans à boulogne-sur-mer
dans un centre de vaccination en
compagnie également de gérald darmanin
cela vient de recevoir un sms d'une
collègue de bretagne qui me dit que eux
aussi sont obligés par la rs de balancer
la 7e dose donc là vraiment alors là
c'est kimura lançant monsieur salomon
balançons tous ces gens qui sont
incapables
je ne voulais pas que à l'échelle du
pays nous ayons 40 ou 50 centres géant
en plein hiver en demandant des
personnes âgées de 90 ans de faire deux
ou trois heures de route et de faire
ensuite la queue dehors pour pouvoir se
faire vacciner
donc le choix que nous avons fait c'est
le choix de multiplier les centres de
vaccination partout là où cela faisait
sens je viens de recevoir aussi un sms
d'une personne d'un médecin qui va se
faire opérer du nez pâtes etc tommy
parce qu'elle a un cancer et c est qu
elle cherche désespérément une dose
files heure là je peux vous dire mais
moi j'ai dit j'ai vraiment des envies de
dalé dézinguer le ministère quoi un peu
plus tôt dans l'après midi des milliers
de parisiens s'étaient donné rendez vous
pour profiter du beau temps
vous séparer alors les policiers passés
dans les groupes nombreux pour faire de
la prévention
nous avons trouvé hier que la méthode
était un petit peu abrupte donc on nous
en discuterons avec la préfecture de
police rappelle que lorsque les gens
sont en extérieur ils sont infiniment
moins en danger que lorsqu'ils sont en
intérieur cette question de de
l'exiguïté des appartements des
conditions de vie elle et elle est
vraiment au coeur au coeur de la de la
réponse qu'on m'a donnée il ya une
immense lassitude ça fait un an
polémique à sciences po grenoble les
photos de deux professeurs ont été
affichées par des élèves dans
l'établissement a sorti de ces mots
fasciste islamophobe
une enquête a été ouverte pour injures
publiques quand on jette en pâture des
enseignants et qu'on les accuse sans
aucune preuve en leur mettant quasiment
une cible dans leur dos je considère que
c'est du terrorisme intellectuel
je n'ai pas peur je défends ou efforts
les droits que nous garantit notre
constitution et surtout la liberté de
débat dans la sphère universitaire qui
je dois hélas et cette affaire illustre
à merveille et menacer gravement par une
minorité qui veut s'imposer
l'université doit porter plainte contre
les étudiants aux côtés des enseignants
eux mêmes
à titre personnel on compte les
étudiants qui ont les étudiants contre
les étudiants et contre l'organisation
contre le nom et l'unef doit se
désolidariser de sa branche de grenoble
scandalisé évidemment je condamne
fermement 1 que six mois après
l'assassinât même pas de samuel pâti des
noms soit je sais je ainsi jeté en
pâture
c'est une façon de mettre la cible en
disant si vous voulez savoir où tirer ou
si vous voulez savoir qui décapite et on
vous donne des noms une espèce de délire
qui fait qu' on ne parle plus on ne
pense plus on n'échange plus le temps où
les politiques étaient intouchables est
révolu notre phrase du jour est signée
françois hollande dans une interview au
parisien l'ancien président de la
république défend le parquet national
financiers créés sous son quinquennat
est vivement critiquée après la
condamnation de nicolas sarkozy et il
restait le l'ombre de monsieur sarkozy
qui s'il avait été candidat
absorbé immédiatement toute la lumière
et aurait sans doute rassembler son
corps en feu les premiers tours de roues
un tour de roue à son rythme un six
mètres et demi en 33 minutes c'est pas
beaucoup et ça fait quand même des
belles images on voit sur ce sol martien